whenever people talk about investing the
terms risk and reward tend to come up a
lot and they usually tend to come up
together somehow implying that the more
risk you take the more reward that you
might be able to get and that's actually
what it is implying but what i want to
do in this video is give a little bit of
an introduction to that or a little bit
context a little bit more structure on
how do you think about risk and reward
so let's say that we have a thousand
dollars and we want to figure out what
we can do with this thousand dollars
well one option is we could just put it
into a savings account so here is one
option so we could put it
into a savings account
and in this situation our
reward i'll start with a reward first is
we'll get i don't know one percent in
interest per year one percent annual
annual interest so after a year we'll
have roughly a thousand and ten dollars
we got one percent on our thousand
dollars so we get a little bit of reward
what's our risk so the risk here i'll
write risk in a different color
what is the risk here
well if i'm putting it into a savings
account and assuming i'm putting it into
an fdic insured savings account let me
put that over here if you do open a
savings account it should be fdic
insured that means that it's being
insured by the federal reserve which
means that if for whatever reason that
that bank were to fail above uh below
some limit the the fed will insure your
money so even if this bank fails and it
loses all of its money and everything
you'll still get your deposit back so if
you're in investing or if you're putting
money in an fdic insured savings account
your risk your risk is essentially zero
you will get you are guaranteed to get
that thousand dollars back regardless of
what happens to that bank so you have
very little risk there but you might say
look you know this is a good risk but i
i feel like i can get more than one
percent on my money let me let me think
about the other places that i could
invest it
well you could
and obviously i'm not going to be
exhaustive on all of the different
investment options i just want to give
you a sense of risk and reward you could
say well let me maybe i can lend the
money to a very reputable company so let
me say
lend
money
to
reputable company
reputable
company and maybe this company has you
know taught you know billions and
billions of dollars in assets it's been
around for hundreds of years it
generates cash on a regular basis
there's really very few circumstances in
which you can imagine that this company
would not be able to pay off its debt
and you lend money to a reputable
company by essentially buying their
bonds
when you buy their when you buy a
company's bonds
you are lending money to that company so
that's just the way you should think
about it so the reward here if you lend
your money to this company
they will pay you six percent
in annual
in annual interest on your thousand
dollars so six percent on the first
thousand
on the or the first year you'd get sixty
dollars it's six times more than what
you're getting in the savings account
what's the risk here well it's not zero
anymore it's not fdic insured the
federal reserve isn't saying that
they'll either give the money if if the
bank goes out of business or they'll
print the money if they don't even have
it here the risk is is that the business
defaults on the loan
so the business
business
defaults
on the loan so the company itself might
go bankrupt if it goes bankrupt then all
the people that the company owes money
to will go after that company's assets
but maybe you are low on the pecking
order maybe the company doesn't have
enough assets to pay everyone back so
there is some risk any business could go
out of business you never know what
might happen but since you since this is
a very reputable company and as we said
it has a lot of assets it has a very
stable business it does good in in boom
times and recessions this is a low risk
of business default so i'll write low
risk right over here because we're
assuming it is a reputable it is a
reputable company that has a lot of
assets and all the rest
now let's say that even that six percent
you know it's all right but you feel
like you could get you could get more
you could do better so let's say that
you have a
friend who is a
let's say that he's just starting his
career as a
as a doctor so he's he has a nice stable
job
so he's just starting his career as a
doctor so stable income
stable income
he's making two hundred thousand dollars
he's making two hundred thousand dollars
a year but he's just out of medical
school and he figures he wants to he
wants to buy a house and so he's trying
to find people so he's just starting he
wants to find people who can help him
with the down payment on the house
so here your reward
and he says anyone who's willing to lend
to me
i will give them
i will give them eight percent
annual interest on their money
annual interest
and and it looks pretty good stable
income it's only a thousand dollars he's
not buying an outlandishly expensive
house he's buying a two hundred thousand
dollar house on which he wants to put
forty thousand dollar down payment seems
well within his means to pay it but
there is always some risk
there is always some risk that he
doesn't pay
doesn't pay
i mean who knows
hopefully this doesn't happen maybe
something happens to him himself maybe
he's not able to work as a doctor maybe
something happens to his health maybe he
has
some type of addictive personality and
and he likes to drink away all of his
money or he likes to gamble it away and
that's actually why he needs loans to
begin with so there is some risk so
there's a risk that he doesn't pay but
by all indications he looks like a
pretty safe character but it's
definitely riskier than this company
because you have no assets to go after
if he doesn't pay companies can't
randomly get hit by a bus a human being
can so there are you know companies for
the most part
cannot become alcoholics a human can who
knows we don't know there but there are
definitely more risks associated with
this individual doctor who does not have
assets you can go after but maybe this
is also not enough reward you're like
you know i heard that i can do even
better i can do better than this in the
stock market
so you look at another option so let's
say you invest in the market
invest in the market
invest
in
stock market
in stock market and you're just going to
invest in a bunch of you know
a broad portfolio kind of investing in
the market as a whole the reward here
would be the expected return of the
market so you look at historical results
in the market you say look it goes up
and down every year but over long
periods of time it looks like people and
this isn't the exact number but it looks
like people have averaged approximately
10
10 percent per year so that looks pretty
good but what's the risk
well the risk is is that
this expectation is just based on
historical uh what the historical turns
returns in the market were there are
huge periods of time in the market i'm
talking 10 20 30 years where the market
is flat where the market could even go
down people could in any given year the
market could go down in the double
digits or you know in the 30 40 percent
even in really really bad years that we
really don't you you really don't aren't
sure whether you're going to get your 10
per year so i would say the risk here is
volatility
volatility and volatility just means it
could go up and down it can it jumps up
and down it's not going to be a constant
upward trend like your savings account
will be volatility
volatility and you have a good chance
that you could actually lose the money
that you're investing it could go down
in any year and any month in any five
years in any 10 years so once again it
seems it seems like a kind of risky
thing and you can very easily lose
everything and let's say that even 10
isn't enough for you you say hey i want
to look at things that maybe i could get
even a better return
so you have a your brother-in-law who's
been out of work for a little bit so let
me write the brother-in-law right over
here
your brother-in-law has been out of work
for a little bit
and he says that all he needs to start
his new guaranteed money making scheme
is a thousand dollars so he can buy the
equipment so that he can start it up in
his garage and the reward
the reward and there's multiple ways we
could set up the reward we could make it
so that he borrows the money for you we
can make it so that you own part of the
business
so let's say the reward is you get a 50
stake in the business 50 stake in
business
in the business
and
let's say that your brother-in-law is
right and this becomes a million dollar
business and it becomes a million dollar
business
million
dollar
business
so this is a very very very high reward
if what your brother-in-law is telling
you is correct but what's the risk
well the risk here is obviously that
he's not correct and that he squanders
all of your money so lose everything
lose everything
and not only could you lose
the monetary money that you put in it
could also ruin your relationship with
your brother-in-law and maybe your
spouse
so risk relationships
relationships maybe i should put you
risk family
family happiness
once your brother-in-law loses all of
your money won't be so easy at
thanksgiving anymore to have a have a
civil conversation so in general the
overlying you know i probably did more
of these scenarios than i needed to but
i think you see the general trend the
more risk that you take in general the
more of a reward you should expect to
get or the more reward that you're
expecting to get there's probably some
risk there and if there's if there's
something that looks like it's really
safe with really high reward one of
those two things are probably not true
so if we were to plot all of these and i
haven't really quantified i haven't i
haven't kind of given you a way of of
measuring risk in future videos we can
think about that and academics have
thought about ways of measuring risk so
that's risk and reward if you plot it
all over here so the savings account
it's zero risk
so this is a savings account over here
it's zero risk and you your reward is
one percent so this is one percent right
over here the lending to a reputable
company it's a little bit higher risk so
this is this one right over here it's a
little bit higher risk and your reward
is six percent so let's say this is six
percent right over here so it's a little
bit higher risk i'm just saying risk is
increasing if you lend to the doctor so
let me pick another color here that i
haven't used if you lend to the doctor
once again the risk is a little bit
higher than lending to that company or
the savings account once again a little
bit higher reward
a little bit higher reward you now have
an eight percent reward investing in the
stock market
let me pick a color i haven't used yet
investing in the stock market once again
higher risk but also a higher reward
maybe 10 percent per year
that's 10 right over there your
brother-in-law super high risk probably
off the charts over here but also super
high reward so maybe it might be like
that but the general idea is the more
risk the more reward